is sexism an everyday reality in the
business world in the beginning of my
career I was the victim of two sexual
assaults and the stream of obscene
comments I was young and I was afraid to
speak out I even thought it was my fault
because I was dressed so sexy the
problem is that sexist and only hits the
headlines when the men are high profile
figures like Donald Trump happy wasting
all Travis kalanick the former boss of
uber who didn't stop sexism in his
company but I have no doubt it also goes
on in other companies I'm Erin and a
veteran who came to prominence after
launching the hashtag outside or south
beck inviting women to make their
experiences of harassment public
[Music]
men and power do you think the business
world is infested with sexism I think
our whole society is infested with
sexism so of course the business world
does is not an exception do you think
putting women in the power would bring
an end to these attacks if the culture
especially in the business world is so
toxic we need to change the culture in
itself and not just bringing more women
into the system especially when then
they are supposed to be fixing it you
know we should all be fixing it it's a
societal responsibility and why don't
women defend themselves I think that's
actually the wrong question to ask we
should be more asking why are men still
doing this you know and what is the
breeding ground in our society that this
is still yeah this is still happening
basically where does it come from why is
it still so normalized so women and men
of the world speak out and go public
otherwise we will never break the system
that makes women victims
[Music]